en faire un dernier point sur la
situation à Kiev plus particulièrement
une vingtaine de kilomètres de la
capitale
ukrainienne à irpinnes c'est là que vous
vous trouvez Cyril païen pour France 24
bonjour à vous Cyril tout à l'heure il y
a quelques instants sur notre antenne
vous expliquer que c'est le feu annoncé
normalement également dans la ville de
Kiev n'était manifestement pas tenu vous
entendiez vous-même des bombardements là
vous vous trouviez avec georgiès bec
oui effectivement donc passé avec
Georges plusieurs heures dans la ville
d'ERP donc nous sommes ici au dernier
checkpoint avant les 5 km qui sont je
peux vous le dire assez dangereux à
franchir puisqu'il y a des bombardements
incessants des tirs d'artillerie des
explosions qu'on entend nous avons passé
quelques heures ici même sur ce front du
nord-ouest de kif hier et là on a
réellement changé de scénario il y a
vous pouvez le voir des membres des
forces spéciales d'ukrainienne qui sont
présentes il n'était pas la lierre on a
vu beaucoup de blindés se positionner se
positionner vers le vers le le front je
ne sais pas si vous entendez des
explosions donc on est vraiment dans un
scénario d'accélération des tensions et
alors là et alors là évidemment on a pu
en parler aux gens qui étaient évacués
de plus en plus nombreux de cette zone
résidentielle il n'y a pas eu de
cessez-le-feu il n'y a pas de corridors
humanitaires dans cet endroit du
nord-ouest de kif les combats n'ont
certainement pas cesser alors comme nous
avons pu aller à pied dans la ville
c'est une ville morte est une ville dont
on voit qu'il y a encore et bien les
stigmates d'une vie normale du c'est une
ville résident résidentielle très habité
et là c'est une ville comme si le temps
s'était arrêté c'était très frappant et
on a pu voir au à l'entrée de la ville
et bien les premiers bunkers les
premières positions des militaires du
chrétien qui n'étaient pas là hier il
commence à défendre la position
c'est-à-dire qu'à quelques kilomètres
seulement du centre-ville de Kiev avec
des tireurs d'élite qui continue
d'affluer là-bas et qui protège
l'évacuation des derniers civils qui
partent de la région d'erpine et de
butcha encore une fois dans le périmètre
de 20 km au nord-ouest de la capitale il
y a des tireurs d'élite positionnés un
peu un peu partout pour
pour protéger pardon la sortie de ces de
ces civils donc des scènes encore
extrêmement difficile de cet exode alors
qu'il y a des bombardements et de plus
en plus alors que je vous parle et bien
des civils qui sont évacués avec les
forces d'autodéfense mais également
de plus en plus de militaires qui sont
venus prêter main forte ici à la
résistance la mobilisation nationale
merci beaucoup Cyril pas bien merci à
Georgias Beck qui vous accompagne et
évidemment vous retrouvera pour refaire
le point et puis surtout soyez prudent
natacha vesnitch est avec nous